we always talk about the creator
everything is the creator every god
created everything god created
everything and then we prayed everything
but god
and that just doesn't make any sense i
said god created everything yes he did
okay then why don't you pray to the
creator then it's all done there's our
father who art in heaven
our father by itself separates him from
god because when he says our he's
equating himself with his audience
christians didn't think women had a soul
forever right
i mean here's the quran 1500 years ago
or so
telling us that
this is
where you're going to be punished from
or pulled out through when you're a bad
guy slam alaikum i'm dr daniel
abdulrahman mcbride i'm a chiropractor
here in central florida i am really
excited to be part of the dean show with
brother eddy
my next guest dr daniel abdulrahman
mcbride dc has been a physical
educational teacher
certified strength and conditioning
specialist firefighter and since 1995 a
chiropractor using functional
neurology to help brain injury and
trauma
1995 is the same year he also accepted
submission to the one god islam
dr mcgraw's path to islam was a simple
one he was raised as a catholic
graduating from a catholic high school
with the biggest takeaway from there
that there is one almighty creator god
the main thought then became how do i
worship him correctly while in
chiropractic school he read the
autobiography of malcolm x and began to
investigate islam
he has given
he was given the quran from a friend and
found that this is the right way to
worship since accepting islam he has his
family have been blessed with the
opportunity to experience islam while
living in the bahamas south africa and
finally returning to be was here on the
dean show
in south florida pumping up
how are you
how about yourself good good
alhamdulillah
so tell us about this uh early journey
so you grew up as a christian catholic
absolutely
and from there tell us a little about
the early years
well it like
the brother was saying earlier we we
talk about the exposure we get and
the brother malcolm x
and of course at the time being very
white i couldn't be part of the nation
and that's all i was exposed to
growing up in white america and then
when i by the time you finish that book
and you come to the acceptance of
orthodox islam is the right path to take
the next step allah blessed me with the
opportunity to read the quran i was
halfway through it i called the local
masjid and the imam invited me over and
said if if this is what you believe this
is what you have to do we made my
shahada and and we've been learning ever
since
in the early years it was captain just
reading a little bit about your
highlights of your story and this is
what i've seen that really
beholds you know really takes a hold of
people is that pure monotheism it's so
strong and you can't take it for granted
you knew that there was one almighty god
yes
yeah the
christianity catholicism catholicism
which i was exposed to um we always talk
about the creator everything is the
creator every god created everything god
created everything and then we prayed
everything but god
i i right say that again say it again
literally
we were raised as as a catholic i was
raised to believe god created everything
and then we pray to everything else one
of my younger brothers is is
into christianity now and
he says you know everything in the name
of jesus and that's you know that
obviously a sin
for us and
i said well if you believe jesus is part
of god then why can't you just say god
and he just spends hours
making no sense whatsoever and arguing
why he can't say god
and that just doesn't make any sense i
said god created everything yes he did
okay then why don't you pray to the
creator then it's all done and if you
think jesus is god pray to god
well i am i'm praying to jesus no you're
not if if you can't say the name
then you are praying to what you label
and what you describe
you know we put
on our dollar bills here in america we
say in god we trust
there's there's no way you worship the
dollar in god at the same time
and and you can't pray to something else
or to another name and and
live with the idea that you're praying
to god at least i couldn't
how was the temple the um i'm sorry how
was the
the climate
same thing with you towards you know at
that time with the on the ground towards
islam at that time in 1995 um
there was no personally there was just
no pushback my parents thought it was
just a phase i was going through
and they figured i'd grow out of it so
there was no pressure
in any direction
i think the biggest pressure comes from
my side
worrying about
being the only mcbride in heaven you
know at the time and now we have you
know i'm blessed with the children and
the family
now did you go back to like most
christians they go back to their pastor
they go back to the preacher they go
back to their church and say look i have
some questions i'm trying to figure out
this trinity i believe in god did you go
back and wrestle with no no
there was it's it's clear that
alhamdulillah a lot chose me to be a
muslim he chose each and every one of us
to be a muslim so after that
it's it's
very linear i mean there's there's
nothing else to wrestle with i'm for me
um some people may um i i tend to be
very linear about a lot of things and
there was no there's no going back i
mean islam is the only
monotheistic religion so there's no
discussion or thought process with any
other option
but now the christian says look but
who's dying for your sins now who's
paying the price for your sins what do
you say
man how can you think someone else is
going to be burdened with the sins i
created and how unfair is that
i it just doesn't make any sense and
then when you think about it
if jesus really died for all of our sins
then
then we can go with why be good at all
right i mean because he already died so
then there's no reason to be good people
at all but the idea is think about what
takes place
if if we're going to think jesus is
great because he died for our sins
the muslim perspective of jesus being
raised to heaven alive because we all
die and go to heaven if god forgives us
well
i think it's a greater
honor
to go to heaven alive as we know jesus
did and then come back because i don't
expect to do that
that makes i mean about you know the
whole thing about jesus was a non-issue
for me also there was no
um
how do you say there's no
there's no trinity it never makes sense
three never makes one yeah it just
doesn't work so it wasn't a problem with
you one that you you're you didn't have
no resistance from family from friends
from you or so at that time you didn't
work for anybody so you didn't you're
working for yourself
no no i've always worked for other
people yeah but it's a non-issue it was
not an issue no
so how do you from what you see today
now
where it seems like it's become an issue
what what do you tell people now people
who are in your situation they don't
believe god is three in one you know not
a lot of this stuff you know when they
look at the authenticity of the bible
you know they're questioning but they
come to islam they may watch some of our
programs they've read the quran and they
see like wow this really makes sense but
now
the pushback right they might have an
employer they might have family members
and islam is of the devil you know
you're joining a call you're going to
turn into a terrorist right yeah what
advice do you have for him the idea is
that
there's enough
stress out there in the world
that you really have to find your
comfortable spot
you do i'm it's it's it's it's been hard
we all all of us have struggled at one
time or another we have bosses that
cheat us outside of our religion we have
um co-workers that disrespect us outside
of the religion so
it for me it simplified things if
someone's going to treat me poorly
because of my religion well that's only
one thing and that i can deal with it's
really such a
simple answer it's a simple question
what do you do you just get away from it
you literally i mean right now
with what i do in functional neurology
it all revolves around the brain
and you are what you tell yourself you
are
literally you can influence yourself
that that quickly that directly um
and the brain is constantly changing the
brain will change and adapt to what you
put in it
and you're in total control of what you
put in yourself
and and there's there's just no room
from my perspective to allow anybody to
put that bad stuff in
your first exposure to the quran did you
have someone
so you said someone gifted you a quran
yeah they actually um i i was talking
while i was in chiropractic school in
atlanta i was just discussing with close
friends that
it was something i was interested in i
always wanted to know how to pray to god
correctly and
i mentioned the autobiography of malcolm
x and they said oh my goodness i i was
interested years ago and i still have a
quran someone let me borrow they gave it
to me
and i got halfway through and that was
the end of it this was exactly it just
made sense the quran even in the english
translation just completely made sense
to me like the brother was mentioning
all the prophets in there i had already
studied about the quran just provided me
with a cleaner option
of all those stories
and then it added to it there's just a
beautiful addition to the thoughts i
already had i like what
you were
questioning you're like okay i believe
in one and only one god not three in one
just one leave it alone don't add or
delete to it and now how do you worship
because a lot of people it's in their
fit their nature to believe but now they
just use god almighty as a you know a
genie nobody when i need something you
know i just rub this no it doesn't work
like that you were thinking like how do
i actually worship the one god how do i
search them correctly if they want me to
pray every sunday all day and kneel down
and stand up and kneel down and stand up
and kneel down and stand up
then prayer is probably important and
you see it across the board you know
multiple religions and i wanted to do it
correctly yeah i did a lot of
black baptist churches some of you may
be familiar with very enthusiastic i
thought maybe it's the level of
sincerity
but then it goes back to
where you're taking that faith and and
where you're taking that sincerity and
none of it added up when it's three and
one it just doesn't it doesn't work yeah
if that didn't
fit the theology that's it but they
can't but when you
got a hold of la illah there's nothing
worthy of worship except allah the
creator heavens and earth
this and then muhammad is his messenger
and it's the same way of life that jesus
lived moses abraham they all said
allah and at that time moses was the
messenger abraham was mentioned at his
time jesus at his time was a messenger
not god you know not part of god not a
son of god muhammad just being the last
and final messenger
this is very very you know profound and
deep it is yes how did you feel after
you took your shahada
it it was awesome it was uh i gotta tell
you it was it really is and then like i
said i was already halfway through the
quran so
honestly your life becomes easier you
you tell me what the rules are
and now i know exactly what i'm going to
do and what i'm not going to do if i
don't know the rules then how how fair
is life that's nothing but stress i mean
it's like when the police change the
speed limit all of a sudden and you get
caught well it's not really fair because
you didn't know it changed yeah it does
the quran is is even in the english
translation is is was so clear this is
exactly how we do things this is right
this is wrong these are the rewards
these are the punishments
it makes it easier for me if to be a
father because imagine if i'm wrong and
my child brings the quran to me and says
dad you're supposed to do it this way
well my child's right now i'm not it's
it's really simple my wife and i if we
disagree and she says you know i don't
think that's very islamic you know
you're right
there's there's it it simplifies islam
has simplified my life beyond any
measure i could have imagined your
family did they also accepted islam
yes they um
my wife is also raised in uh as a
catholic um
yeah she's and more devout than i was
she's she's haitian catholic so i mean
that was that's a lot of catholic there
haitian catholic so
and my children were raised that way
yeah so
it's it's uh
we had disagreement one time and she
said she was gonna call her wally
because she didn't think i was right and
i was like wow that's not fair because
then you're probably right then so it
was all done
it's really uh islam is real like i said
the quran is clear
all you have to do is pull up the verse
i mean even with with the chiropractic
that i practice there's a verse
there's an i uh
15 and 16. if you read the 96 surah and
you read through to 15 and 16 allah
talks about how he's going to pull
or how our souls are going to be pulled
out through the english translation i
said i have says through our forelocks
right through our foreheads through
they're going to be ripped out for a
believer it's just a little perspiration
perspiration
with my functional neurology where what
area now do you think science should
support religion and your religion
should support your science they're if
they're right
where do you think you make that final
decision whether you just do something
or you inhibit that bad action
that's the forehead that's the frontal
lobes that's the forelock that's the
brain there's no way we knew that 1500
years ago
i mean remember just a few hundred years
ago
people thought women didn't have a brain
they thought you know the christians
didn't think women had a soul forever
right
i mean here's the quran 1500 years ago
or so
telling us that
this is
where you're going to be punished from
or pulled out through when you're a bad
guy
and that's that's your final inhibition
that's your final initiation of the good
or bad you decide to do it's the
forehead it's the forelock so
it's really science religion it all
agrees
for me
let's take some questions from the
audience
uh
before i ask my question i want to say
thank you so much for joining us today
in south florida i know you came a long
way
but thank you for you actually
to humble yourself
and us as a millennium sitting with the
with the youth here in the front line
not looking for a chair or anything
that's uh for me it's uh
it means a lot
it means a lot
so thank you for you for giving us a
listen without telling us this is a
lesson
uh number my question is actually uh
you are you're a doctor and you are in
high rank stage of career in your life
and you meet a lot of high stage career
in life
how you develop your your message
among
all stage of people when it comes to at
least two minutes conversation about
islam
i don't want to say manipulate the
message
but
going through the message
and
thank you so much
the i think brother abu bakr said it
really well
when
people meet us
we should show our belief
it should be all over us it really my
co-workers the the people in the office
that i i'm in
uh they
when when people bring us food to the
office you know there's a doctor's
office they want to encourage our
business and there's that those gifts
and things they tell them that i eat
halal
my my coworkers a lot of them voted for
president trump just out of control
right so
think about what takes place there those
same people make sure i get fed well
when food comes in they clear it for me
i don't even have to say anything
so it's literally it's it's how we
project ourselves it's it's if if if
you're somebody
a brother down here i respect
more than than most um
all of you may know him brother nasser
this this brother can
so honorable so and he fixes cars
now we can say oh he's only a mechanic
no he's a role model he gives us a
hundred percent of his time and effort
and and when i'm down here that's who i
trust you know what i'm saying and then
you can say well i'm a doctor oh my god
there it is
the idea is that
all of our actions should speak for
ourselves so that when people come to us
people apologize when they curse in
front of me in the office
they apologize to me and i don't even
say anything because they know i don't
like it and it's it's just
it's that line like you talked about it
this is the way we behave and this is
what i expect around me
so if that makes if that answers the
question
and the moment we from miami
all the way to makkah
we we speaking about publish a book
actually we are next to each other
and masha'allah
that's why i'm actually
you have to tell the people about the
books you published for everybody to
have it
and i i know you're not feeling
he liked he don't like actually to
public himself but he published many
many books actually brother abdullah
friday known for four years and also the
very important to the names of your kids
please
[Laughter]
see the brother's gonna embarrass me and
make me cry up here in front of
everybody i'm gonna have to grow a big
beard to catch it all right
um
yes my children
malik
khadijah tahara and abdulrahman
the girls couldn't be here of course i
told them right away we were going to be
here uh tahara looked you up right away
she had to give me the scoop what little
i already knew but what little she felt
i didn't know she had to fill me in
the one of the first books we did was
who's right who's wrong and why
islam christianity and judaism and what
we did was
we
we took
biblical verses and explained
with biblical quotes like like jesus
there's jesus talks about
himself as a prophet he he mentions
prophet all the time he says
uh at one point there's a verse in there
pray as you see me pray
you people don't pray to themselves
right i mean it's just pray as you see
me pray uh
if i can use the words if you'll forgive
me
he's there's our father who art in
heaven
our father by itself separates him from
god because when he says our he's
equating himself with his audience and
he never says anybody in his audience is
a god right so he says our father then
he says where is he
of course as muslims we say above the
heavens but he's clearly differentiating
just those two sentences by themselves
and and we we spent 13 chapters
explaining why the bible doesn't work to
the point where in the old testament
there's a verse that says and you can
and google everything up grab a king
james version on your computer and
google up worms and it even says in the
old testament that a man born of a woman
is less than a worm
so we've got to kind of rule out anybody
that's born of a woman being a god
so uh it's really and you got to
remember that's a cool reference because
when we die what are we going to do
we really do
back to the earth and and we become just
just
food for the environment
so it's yeah that's what we
the second one we went more into um and
we're our goal is always to try to
expose non-muslims to islam
and the second book was more
healthcare-oriented
with
some cool verses out of the bible
leading us into verses and into the
quran on how to live a healthy
lifestyle food exercise
we included some hadith in that
where can people get the books uh the
the
the health book
is on amazon
and
that's called uh
god's health care initiative
god's health care initiative and they
just put your name in the name of the
book yeah yeah it should still be
available um
if not i'll write it up and the other
one's who's right who's wrong yes that
we another brother published it here and
we have copies of it um if you want to
you could reach out to brother mirasad
or um brother umar brother roshi yeah
reach out to us and we will
make those arrangements to get you a
copy all right um and that's interesting
you mentioned the lord's prayer islam is
in the lord's prayer oh our lord who art
in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done exactly so
i usually tell christians i mean the
lord's prayers should actually lead you
if you're exactly
doing it properly you're sincerely
praying to one god because it's calling
you to pray to one god exactly right you
should be submitting to one god praying
to him alone
and
not like you said jumping all over the
place all over the place you're playing
everything else and with that you've got
when jesus
the story of the biblical jesus excuse
me the story of the biblical jesus when
he's in the garden
before they're coming to arrest him what
does he do he goes off by himself and he
kneels down and puts his forehead to the
ground and prayed earnestly praying yes
that's that's
christians don't do that we do that
we do that we follow jesus better than
anyone does and we shouldn't allow them
it's it's like current history today
barack obama is only half black
so why do all these white folks insult
his mother and him right and his
grandparents who raised him you've got
to understand we can't let them take
from us what we know is right
we can't do that barack obama is a great
american in the sense i need to agree
with his politics and ideas i'm fine
with that but the idea is he was a much
better person than donald trump was
right and and we let these people push
him in front of us all the time right i
mean we've got to claim what's ours
jesus is ours
there's it's it's done and along with
all of the other prophets they're ours
and literally each one of us whether we
were born
or
accepted islam later in life god chose
each and every one of us to do this
which is is the singularity of that
rather than saying it's someone else and
you do it because it's your parents no
you're here because god chose you to be
here and again
the the idea that that like i said with
with the jesus and the praying and he's
ours
we're the only ones on the right path
that's like actually like hallelujah
[Laughter]
no that kind of scares me sometimes
so that's not a war cried that's
praising the most yes it is
daniel here on the dean's show and you
can do what he did pray to one god alone
that's your homework and you can pick up
a free copy of the quran at the dean
show dot com if you have any other
questions call us
1-800-662-islam we'll see you next time
here on the show peace be with you
assalamu alaikum and if you like this
episode of the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work thank you for tuning in peace be
with you assalamu alaikum